[Music]
all right let's go to james in charlotte
hey james what's going on
how y'all doing today remarkable how
about you man
uh i'm pretty delighted to be honest
with you i'm sorry to hear that what's
up
brother
so uh me and my wife started off last
year uh during the dave ramsey plan and
uh was on baby step two we had 105 000
approximately of consumer debt
and irs debt and we got that down to
about 43 000
and uh hey who knows about eight hold on
let's look real quick you paid off 60
grand in a year
yes
we make uh between 110 to 120 000 a year
okay
i know you're deflated right now we're
gonna get to that but i want to take one
second and just say
that's what's up congratulations
that's awesome
60-something thousand dollars it's
incredible all right so
i guess this this takes a left turn here
somewhere right
yeah um about six months ago we went
through a dss issue and had to hire a
lawyer and go through all the legal
proceedings with that what kind of issue
what kind of issue i did a dss issue
with my kid okay
and uh
so we lost all three of our kids and had
to get them back and
went through all that stuff what
happened
um my kid went to school and basically
used the imagination's imaginative story
and uh
they took it seriously and pursued dss
and
they basically
took us through the winger for no reason
and so dss is the department of job
protective services in your area yes
okay and so they reported some some
some sort of abuse of some sort and they
came in and did an emergency removal
yeah okay and then y'all went through
getting an attorney and you're fighting
to get yourself back
yep and we did get our kids back about a
month ago or so how long have they gone
from you
um about uh two months
okay
i'm sorry to hear that man that's that's
a nightmare
yeah we haven't already got over that
part of it yet and my kids haven't
either they they're not really the same
now either we're going through the whole
counseling thing with them good
so how can we help man
so um i've lost that eight thousand
dollars through that process which i
don't i mean like i don't think that's
like i would spend another eight
thousand dollars get my kids back
but uh like it just threw me off track
and like um
like special economy now with inflation
like when i do my budget i'm just not
like motivated no more
so on the back end of the trauma you and
your family have just experienced
you went to fight or flight you fought
for your kids
you went sprinting after them to protect
them you got everybody back in the house
and that snow globe of your home has
been shaken
not having motivation is totally normal
i want you all to grieve this thing
together lean into that counseling and
then you and your wife are gonna have to
excavate what was and build something
new because you're a family that's
experienced trauma right before the
break we took a call from james in
charlotte north carolina james was
him and his wife were on the same page
and they were just crushing a hundred
thousand dollars worth of debt
and um we ran right up against the break
there james and so i'm glad that you
hung on the line because i want to
circle back a little bit um you guys had
paid off 60 000
in a year
and
for
any number of reasons behind closed
doors there were some conversations at
school with one of your kids and the
child protective services got involved
took your kids away for a while they are
now back but
um you spent a chunk of money 8 000
bucks with attorneys and fighting for
your kids which as you noted
you would have spent 16 you would spend
100 000. i was getting those kids back
in your home but now you're in the
big exhale right things feel like
they're in ash am i right
that's right so walk us through what
what's
what's going on in your home
um
financially no no no i'm talking about
the spirit of your house right now is
everybody deflated and a little bit
terrified and exhausted and mad and all
those things hurt yeah a little bit of
everything am i scared of not knowing
what to expect you're always expecting
another caller visit from dss okay and
uh what's happening in that school when
he goes to school i mean it's just what
he's going through and the guilt he
feels like we try not to make him feel
good about it
but i mean
he's eight years old so he does feel a
little bit and understands a little bit
of the repercussions but not all of it
sure and what about the other kids in
their home are they upset with you guys
with them with everybody
well it was a another kid involved was
uh five years old and then a
one-year-old okay and uh the
one-year-old we kind of lost a little
bit of bonding time with him and a
little bit development delays because he
wasn't in our
care yeah and a five-year-old just going
through a bunch of separation anxiety
yeah
so we're getting them treated for that
as well how long were they going
um
right at two months
two months huh
and normally we don't even go a night
without them but we don't
pawn our kids off and go have fun we
normally just do family stuff all the
time never not working yeah
so now they're not used to being away
from us and we're not you staying away
from them
and this is one of those hard things
because you're a parent of three young
kids and you as someone who loves your
kids and probably the children that your
kids associate with
you want a group of people that will
kick the door in and protect children
from bad parents right yeah because i
was a foster kid there you go
you want that service and at the same
time you're on the other end of a
misunderstanding
and there's that thank god there's group
people like that out in the world and
oh my gosh what a my family just
suffered trauma major trauma yes
how's your marriage
um our marriage is pretty good if it
wasn't good i don't think we would have
made it through them two months okay
everybody in a marriage after a
situation like this people grieve
differently how are y'all grieving
uh my wife uh took it really hard and i
was more on my anger side so like when
she would cry i would like try to shut
that down and i didn't let her grieve
like i should have be honest with you
okay
um i just because like if i i felt like
if i would have got to the point of the
crime and stuff like i would have lost
everything and my
emotional well-being
and i couldn't let that happen at the
time because i had a fight ahead of me i
couldn't
you know what i mean by my so i don't
think i
went through the grieving process
correctly and i don't think i'd let her
do that as well okay
so um
here's what i want you to do
you've got all three kids back how long
have y'all been back
together um i said a month but i think
it's about two months now because we
went we just did our family vacation a
weekend ago okay how was that
uh it was pretty good just rushed okay
but i felt like it was it kind of put my
kids in a better place emotionally
so before i start answering questions
that i want to answer what
how can i help you brother
so like i'm like really i could be debt
free tomorrow uh the only thing hold me
back is two vehicle loans okay
and uh where i put myself and then like
when i budget to do that like
everyone said like now
like i guess because the anticipation of
something coming up now it just
like i can't go all in no more like i
feel like i gotta hold back and wait to
see what else is gonna happen
how honest you want me to be with you
100 okay
somewhere along the way probably when
you were one or two years old
four or five or six or seven or eight
nine or ten years old you learned
i cannot be vulnerable it'll get me
killed
yeah
you're a foster kid you still
that still hangs over you like a cloud
sometimes on a bad day is that fair
that's right and at the same time you're
grateful for the people who took you in
that fair
that's correct okay so you live in this
toggled world back and forth and back
and forth
and what you have done over the last how
old are you
i'm 36 okay the last
three decades
is you got real real strong
real strong
and in counseling we call it leakage
and that's a dirty diaper term but the
reality is this you can deal with that
stuff
or it will deal with you
it will come out in rage it will come
out in anger it will come out in unable
to take a firm next step and so you end
up just shutting down and shutting down
if you think of like a like one of those
one of those machines at the dump that
crushes cars and just presses down your
feelings and your emotions and your
relationships another word for that is
it will depress everything
yeah so that's where i'm at that's where
you are that's exactly right so i want
you to know two things number one your
body's working just like it's designed
to
and
you can heal
and you'll be able to take a full breath
again if you choose to
the choice there starts with sitting
with your wife one night after your kids
are in bed
and looking her in the eye and holding
both of her hands and saying
i didn't let you grieve this i didn't
let you cry and i'm sorry
and then following that up with i don't
know how to grieve and cry and i feel
like if i start crying i won't ever be
able to stop
and what you're going to do it's
completely counter-intuitive
to enter a fight on your on your back
right
yeah
and what the only way through this is
through connection and relationship and
the only way to connection relationship
is through being vulnerable and being
honest and saying the words i hurt
i'm scared i'm sorry
and those aren't three words that have
served you well in the past because
you've had to be really tough to
navigate a really hard hard row right
that's right do you love that woman
yes i do you trust her
yes now's the chance to turn it all
around
when you connect you'll be able to
breathe you'll be able to sleep for the
first time in four months
that's right and when she says how can i
help you and you're honest with her
you'll be able to breathe and sleep and
when you ask her how can i best serve
you right now how can i help you grieve
because i know we're gonna grieve
different and that doesn't mean you got
to cry on the floor and kick and scream
and write poetry to yours that is
everyone grieves differently
but you got to be honest about what you
need
and then
you can go into the money stuff
but the money stuff is the fear about
the money is a symptom of
a heart that is still in fight or flight
a brain an amygdala that's still burning
bright waiting for the next knock on the
door
you get what i'm saying
yeah and i know i know i know my brother
this is scary and this is all new and
these are these are skills you haven't
used before
and so you're gonna have to practice it
you're gonna goof it up and you're gonna
feel awkward and you're gonna feel
scared and you're gonna backtrack all
those things are good but your wife's
got to know i'm in with you and that
starts with i'm sorry i should have let
you cry and i don't know what to do and
i thought that if i started crying i
would never ever stop
and you're you're not man george so many
of us learned that skill right cover up
man
and stick your chest out and just go out
swinging that's just that's what so many
of us know to do and it feels
counterintuitive it feels unsafe to back
down and look at somebody and say i'm
scared i don't know what to do next yeah
and we're seeing all over the country
man the research on on leaders who came
out during the
um last 18 months and tried to flex and
snap into a swim gym their way through
this
they are cracking the people underneath
them are leaving in droves and those
leaders who came out and said i don't
know what's next we're going to rally
around we're going to work really hard
and we get new information we're going
to change our minds different
their people are staying and they're
staying and they're being successful
they're pivoting and moving same same
thing works in relationships and it
marriages yeah it's a hard hard season
my brother and scary and i'm sorry that
your family experiences trauma
healing is up to you and your wife and
it comes today start today brother james
this is the ramsay show